[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
30 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with Mark Mandel, my colleague.
Hey, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc,
how are you feeling?
You've been on a bit
of a long journey.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
a little bit sore, you
know, like biking 600 miles.
Apparently [INAUDIBLE]
makes you tired, it's weird.
MARK MANDEL: Who knew?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, who knew?
Very happy to be
sitting on chairs
that are slightly bigger
than the one on my bike.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes,
very happy about that.
And today's episode 30, which
is a pretty good number.
Very, very, very big
number, 30 already.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
proud of you, man.
You've done a good job.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, you too.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not as good
as mine, but pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, thanks.
All right.
Well, I'll bring my game up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and to celebrate
that we have episode
number 30, we're actually
bringing not one, not two,
but three guests today.
MARK MANDEL: It's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So, we're going to have three
different product managers,
actually two product managers
and one technical program
manage.
So Kir Titievsky from Google
Cloud Pub/Sub, Eric Anderson
from Google Cloud
Dataflow, and Tino Tereshko
from Google BigQuery.
And we're going to be
talking about basically how
you can do big data and
analytics for mobile.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so there's
actually a gaming solution
that you could probably
apply to several other things
on your website
that we can go to.
And we're going to
step through that,
and sort of look at all
the different pieces
that enable that, and
why you should use those.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we're going to be talking
a lot about big data
during the main content,
but also during the
question of the week.
The question of the week is
going to be about BigQuery.
But before we even
start with those,
we have the cool thing of
the week, and guess what?
It is about BigQuery too.
MARK MANDEL: It's
another BigQuery point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
It's BigQuery everywhere.
And I'm not sure if we're
excited about this one,
because I used to
do a lot of SQL.
And as you might
know Google BigQuery
supported a dialect of SQL
that was very similar to SQL.
But there were some
slight differences.
Well, the latest version
has standard SQL now.
So if you know SQL, you
just know BigQuery now.
So that is pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That
is pretty cool.
I know when I was
using it, especially
like things around JOINS
and stuff like that.
And you try and do it, and then
you'd be like, uh, I can't.
And then you'd read the
docs, and they're like,
oh, just add this extra
special little thing that's
just extra special.
And if you didn't know what it
was, you were kind of stuck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So now everything
is just standard SQL.
Which is great, I'm
very excited about that.
There's also support for IAM.
So we did an episode not
that long ago about identity
and access management.
So you have a finer
control on who can access
and who can do what on BigQuery.
And then you were pretty
excited about the last one,
the time-based
table partitioning.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so you
no longer have to actually
manually span out
your partition,
say like this is January,
[INAUDIBLE] February,
et cetera.
BigQuery's going
to do that for you
out of the box, which
just means it's a little
less work that you need to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
less work is always better.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
The episode today, it's
going to be kind of long.
So why don't we go and talk
directly to our friends
from the big data?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: We are joined
today by three product
managers talking about
Gaming Analytics Platform.
We are joined by Kir
Titievsky, Eric Anderson,
and Tino Tereshko.
I think I got that
vaguely right.
Was that vaguely close?
TINO TERESHKO: Got it.
Better than most people.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
I'm pretty excited,
because this is the
most number of people
we've been interviewing
on the podcast ever.
So it's going to be
a bit interesting.
But I think it's going
to go pretty well.
So before we get stuck sort
of into the meat of it,
why don't we sort of
get you all to tell us
all a little about yourselves?
I'm going to go
based on the order
that I have in the document.
So Kir, do you want to go first,
tell us a little about yourself
and who you are?
KIR TITIEVSKY: Hi there.
I'm Kir Titievsky, and
I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
I've long been
trying to figure out
how exactly to explain
why I'm excited about it.
And it finally struck me today.
It's that it made
networking asynchronous.
It's fast, but
it's asynchronous.
You know how when the
first kind of network,
you could just call somebody?
You can call somebody on the
phone, and if they were there,
you could have a
synchronous conversation.
If they were not
there, you were stuck.
Now, email came
along and it made
that whole thing asynchronous,
so you could just instantly
shoot somebody an email
or an instant message.
And it was there if they were
on the other side in a second.
If they're not, it could
wait for them for days.
Pub/Sub did the same thing
for just general networking,
shipping data around.
So that's what
I'm excited about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And what is your
location right now?
I'm just curious about how
many people in different places
we have.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Oh,
this is exciting.
I think we've got the
entire country represented
with the corners.
I'm in New York today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, Eric,
how about yourself?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
I'm Eric Anderson.
I'm a product
manager on Dataflow.
This is, if it's
interesting, I've
been at Google for
three years now.
I've started on a little
data science team.
And I've been on Dataflow
for maybe a year and a half.
Let's see, I'm based normally
in Mountain View, on my way
to New York for
some conferences,
and currently in
Salt Lake City, Utah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And Tino, yourself?
TINO TERESHKO: Hi there.
I'm Tino Tereshko.
I'm a technical program
manager for BigQuery,
which is Google's serverless,
fully-managed, petabyte scale
analytics data warehouse.
BigQuery's used widely
at Google across all
of the Google's organizations.
And we have lots of
really exciting customers
to speak of as well.
And I'm based out of Seattle.
I've been at Google
for almost three years,
and I've been on the BigQuery
team for about a year.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And then we are here
in San Francisco.
So San Francisco, Seattle.
KIR TITIEVSKY: New York.
MARK MANDEL: New York, and
Salt Lake City, was it?
Utah?
ERIC ANDERSON:
That's right, yeah.
Don't forget it.
KIR TITIEVSKY: You
left the coasts,
Eric you left the coasts.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ANDERSON: It's almost
like a layover in between them,
though.
I'll be there shortly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
And then we have Pub/Sub,
we have Dataflow,
and we have BigQuery.
What are the relationships
across all of them?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So we're here sort of talk
about sort of a reference
implementation we've had
on the website for a while.
So we're hearing about building
a mobile gaming analytics
platform, which is a solution
people can go online.
We'll have the link in the show
notes for people, available.
Do one of you three want to
volunteer to sort of talk
about what this is
and how it works?
It seems to kind of cut across
all three of your segments.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Sure.
I'll go first and you guys tell
me when I get things wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
KIR TITIEVSKY: This is Kir.
So, the reason I got
excited about doing
this particular podcast, aside
from being a loyal listener,
is that I recently heard
the interview you guys did
with the gaming company.
It was "War of Dragons," right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Yes.
And they were talking
about their pipeline, which
looked very much like a
reference diagram, which
you can find on the Google Cloud
site, which looks something
like this, for those
of you who are not
looking at the website
who are listening.
It's a client, be it on
your mobile phone or not,
talking to a front
end server, and then
needing to hand over
the data for processing
to a set of three things.
You push the event data
to Cloud Pub/Sub, which
then gets pulled into Dataflow,
where it gets transformed,
where it gets massaged,
where you enrich your data
or strip what you
don't need, and then
you finally put it on
the results in BigQuery.
That's sort of a standard stack.
MARK MANDEL: Just before
you go any further,
do you want to take a step
back and say, what sort of data
are we talking about here?
The reference is mobile
gaming analytics,
but can you give people sort of
an example of what sort of data
we'd be ingesting?
KIR TITIEVSKY: Oh, absolutely.
And by the way, I highly
recommend those of you
who are listening to go back, I
think it would be two or three
episodes, to hear a very
detailed account of how this
works for this, for
"War of Dragons."
But you're just talking
about user events.
Whenever somebody finds
that coin, kills the dragon,
their score goes up,
they bought something.
As a mobile app developer
or a mobile game developer
in particular, you are
interested in understanding
how these events
tie together so you
can start optimizing a game.
So you're looking
for those gems.
Gems of little
interactions that work
are those that slow
down your users.
In a way, this is
sort of the same story
that you might be working on if
you are just optimizing a site.
Think Google Analytics.
For game developers, this
is especially important,
because it's such a dynamic
and competitive field
that you have to
really understand
exactly what the users are
doing at any point of the game.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you've got a bunch
of game data coming in,
players doing stuff, maybe
beating bosses or levels
and stuff, and you need a way
to ingest that and then send
that on somewhere else.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Right.
Ultimately, you
want to make sure
that the game
developers and the data
scientists on the team, who
oftentimes are the same person,
sometimes not depending
on how big the company is,
can actually make
sense of this data.
And so I think BigQuery
is the thing that
makes it possible to examine
the vast volume of data quickly,
but AppStream, so that the
combination of Cloud, Pub/Sub,
and Dataflow are
the things that make
it possible to ingest
the data and transform it
as it's streaming.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So it sounds like,
looking at the diagram,
the first step is Pub/Sub.
So my question is,
OK, why Pub/Sub?
Why is this the first step?
KIR TITIEVSKY: So you can think
of Pub/Sub as another solution
for logging.
If you think about the old
school way of doing things,
your LAMP stack back in the day.
Every time you would
get a web request,
you would respond
to the user and dump
a record to your system
log, or Apache log,
or wherever you had
your setup done.
And so then you might
go and you would
have a subsystem that would
trawl through the logs, put
them in some kind of ETL
loop, and every so often, you
would just sort of ingest
the log, put it into a MySQL
database, and then
somebody on the other end
would go and look
at the data to try
to figure out what's happening.
What's happened as we went
away from having single stacks
to having multiple servers,
or microservices implementing
many of the applications,
especially games,
because they're so
vastly distributed.
As soon as you start talking
about players playing
in different sides
of the country,
if Eric and I were
playing today,
we'd have to somehow communicate
and synchronize things
between a server that's close
to Utah and a server that's
close to New York City.
You're dealing with a system
that's not a single stack.
Something is far
away from that disk.
So, how do you have a solution
that looks a little bit very
quickly writing to log so that
you can process these event
data later, but that works for
a completely distributed set
of microservices
or just servers?
And that's Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is, a silly example,
it's like email or instant
messaging for machines.
Instead of writing to a log, any
machine anywhere in the world
can just put a message
on Pub/Sub and say, hey,
a player just killed the dragon.
Done.
From there on,
the front ends can
focus on servicing the
users, and the back ends
can just read those messages
from Pub/Sub to figure out
what to do with them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so you mentioned
a couple times the
three magic words, ETL.
Could you explain a
little bit what those are
and what that means
for our audience?
KIR TITIEVSKY: I'm glad
that you consider ETL
the magic words, Francesc.
Eric, do you want
to take this one on,
since you're in the middle?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
Yeah, so commonly this is
just extract, transform, load.
So you've got data
in point A and you
want to move it to
point B. Maybe move it,
maybe you're just
looking to change it.
Data's often immutable, and
so changing involves moving.
So you're going from in this
case, Pub/Sub to BigQuery,
you're going to extract
it from Pub/Sub,
transform it, and
load it into BigQuery.
But ETL is traditionally
more often used
when you're moving
database to database,
or file system to database,
anytime you move data around.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so in this case
we could say the E in ETL
could be Cloud Pub/Sub, that's
how you're extracting that
information from all the data
sources?
ERIC ANDERSON: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And what happens next?
ERIC ANDERSON: So, this
moves us into Dataflow.
And that this is the T in ETL.
We're going to
transform the data.
You might be asking
yourself, why
are we transforming the data?
There's a lot of things that
we could do here in Dataflow.
You might be, we mentioned
enriching the data.
So you have raw
events from user.
You may just want to
add a location that
is found elsewhere.
You have the IP
address of the client.
You could transform that now
into a geographical location.
You could be joining the
data against databases
that you have to pull
in additional user data,
to add more color to
your eventual analysis.
A lot of people are doing
schema transformations.
Another situation you
may hit is if you've
got old clients running
some version of the game,
you have newer clients running
another version of the game.
They're sending different
kinds of events.
You could normalize
those schemas in Dataflow
so that everything
that hits BigQuery
is in the shape you expect,
and the shape that's
easy to analyze.
So I guess those
are a few examples
of what you're doing Dataflow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, that means that basically
Cloud Dataflow, what it's
doing, it's just doing
those transformations
to be able to then store
it in some nice way
that you might be interested.
What is Cloud Dataflow exactly?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah,
so Dataflow is a stream
and batch data
processing service.
It's also a programming model.
And a set of SDKs.
That programming model
and SDKs were recently
submitted to Apache, and now
are referred to as Apache Beam.
It's an incubating project.
But we can get into
more of that later.
But the service itself
is, as I said, batch
and stream processing engine.
You describe currently
in Java, very soon
in Python, the transformations
you want to apply on data.
You describe also the sources
that you're going to pull from,
and where you're going to
sync or persist the data when
the transformations are over.
And this, in the case
of Java JAR file,
is sent to the service.
And the service itself
spins up virtual machines
in Google Cloud, and manages all
the complexities of distributed
computing that are
going on there,
including ensuring correctness
and fault tolerance.
And then once that data's
all persisted to your storage
system-- in this
case, BigQuery--
we tear down the VMs,
tear down the job,
and report to you all the
logs and statistics that
happened during the process.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
is it like MapReduce?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah, I
could've started there, yes.
So this is Google's
MapReduce system.
And also a more recent stream
processing system, MillWheel,
combined under a single SDK.
KIR TITIEVSKY: What's really
cool about it is that--
and this is Kir in
New York again--
is that I feel like it works
the same way whether it's
pulling a single
event off Pub/Sub,
or if you're doing
2 million QPS.
You basically just define
a single transformation.
In many cases, if
you're just looking
at a single event at
a time, you don't even
have to know how many events
you're going to process.
Dataflow just abstracts
all of that for you.
Is that right, Eric?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yes, totally.
And maybe taking that
even further, part
of the reason we went
out building Dataflow,
because there's
existing alternatives
in the marketplace,
is the holy grail,
particularly with this gaming
setup, is recreating a session.
You have all of these
complex events coming in
from users all over the place
and different situations.
They all flood the system.
And making sense of that and
aggregate is really tricky.
Dataflow has built-in primitives
to recreate sessions, and allow
you to analyze sessions, which
is typically, ultimately what
people are after here.
We move events from out of order
to in order within Dataflow.
And then once they're
in order, we then
can apply windowing
strategies, we call them,
to group those events.
In this case, I
mentioned sessions
would be really useful.
But yeah, you can group
them by a user session
and then perform some
analytic function on tat user
session like what
happened after this event,
or how many of these
events happened,
what's the average
of those events.
And then can all then be sent
and persisted to BigQuery.
TINO TERESHKO: I'm happy
to add my thoughts on this.
So this is Tino from
the BigQuery team.
What Dataflow allows
you to do-- and Pub/Sub
of course, as
well-- is it really
changed the model
of how developers
look at their game data.
Instead of collecting
kind of summary events,
things like I just picked up
a sword, or things like I just
killed the boss, instead of
choosing which events you want
to collect and analyze
at a future date,
this kind of daisy
chain of services
allows you to look
at everything,
have a holistic
view of your data.
And that really allows
you to analyze your game
from very, very different angles
than ever before possible.
And the second thing
that it allows you to do
is imagine what the map's space
was before Waze came along.
Before Waze, if you had
a section of the road
and you wanted to figure
out what was the traffic
pattern on that road
on Friday between 5
and 6 o'clock in the evening,
you'd have to run a SQL query,
and it would say,
generally at that period,
it's 50 miles an hour, all
right, let's paint it red.
Now with Waze, you have a
real time processing engine
that collects the data, pushes
it through the CTL pipeline,
and feeds it back
into the application.
And so now with
Ways, we know, right
at this moment, that is a
green section of the road.
And you can do the
same thing with gaming.
You can adjust how
your games work
by feeding the data
directly back into the game
itself, which really unlocks
a lot of possibilities
for game developers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so you
can really kind of adjust
your gameplay on the fly,
depending on what events
are happening inside that game.
TINO TERESHKO: Exactly, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
OK, and now we've got
to the E and the T.
Why don't we talk a
little bit about the L?
Guessing the L,
then, is BigQuery?
Would that be correct?
TINO TERESHKO: In
my opinion, the L
is the result of loading
data into the BigQuery.
And once data is
loaded in the BigQuery,
hopefully prepared and
clean and nice to look at,
you're able to analyze that data
through any pure ad hoc data
scientist exploration mode.
You don't have to plan
how you want to analyze
the data in BigQuery.
It gives you the freedom
to look at your data
in any way imaginable.
You can look at historical
data going back several years.
You can look at
data in real time
that gets fed through BigQuery,
through Dataflow and Pub/Sub.
And you can look at massive,
massive amounts of data.
So this holistic
raw data viewpoint
is really enabled by BigQuery.
You can [INAUDIBLE].
I'm sorry, go ahead.
MARK MANDEL: So I think you're
talking about the fourth step.
There's a letter
that we have missed.
It should be either P or M--
P for profit, or M for magic.
I don't know which
one it is, but I
think it speaks to the
point that it's not just
about loading right,
it's about being
able to make sense of the
data in the same place where
you keep the result.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Yep,
that's exactly it.
BigQuery doesn't
require you to think
very hard about whether
you have keys or indexes
or whether your data
sets are too big.
You just load your
data into BigQuery,
and you use plain, regular
standard SQL to analyze it.
And because BigQuery
doesn't require
you to stand up massive
amounts of infrastructure
to leverage massive
for your analysis, the
doors really open up.
You can do a whole lot very,
very quickly with BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
that's a point that
could be made about
all three of the tools
we're talking about here.
I think we're kind of in this
nice level of Google Cloud,
which is managed services.
Neither Pub/Sub nor
Dataflow or BigQuery
require you to provision much.
They're services, they just run.
If you think about doing
ETL in the traditional way,
you have to think about
the physical machines
where this happens.
I still vividly remember once
decommissioning a mainframe.
It was a fun
adventure with moving
a box on wheels and several
people from a data center
into a truck.
You don't even have to
think about that anymore,
in principle, which in my
head is magical in all three
of the steps, but in
BigQuery in particular.
KIR TITIEVSKY: You bring
up a really good point.
There's this new buzzword
that's coming around.
It's actually an old buzzword,
but it's become reinvented,
called serverless.
You're seeing this with Google
Cloud Functions and AWS Lambda.
But serverless generally
applies to tiny little jobs
that get executed without
having to stand up a cluster.
Pub/Sub, Dataflow, BigQuery,
is so [INAUDIBLE] big data.
You're able to analyze
big data at scale
in any way you
want in real time,
without standing up servers.
So serverless big data
is really a reality today
with these services.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
Yeah, just to kind
of recap on some
of that a little bit as well.
It sounds like that the
combination of the three
is exceptionally powerful.
And it sounds like so Pub/Sub
for ingesting messages
at scale, Dataflow for
handling stuff in real time,
even for transformations
but also like analyzing
gameplay and whatnot.
And then BigQuery for
maybe more after the fact.
What can we find out
that we don't already
think we know or go exploring?
Would any of you sort
of agree with that?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yes, certainly.
You described two ways
of stacking these,
and these are the ones that
Tino brought up already.
We could adjust data,
apply transformations
in real time in Dataflow,
and then feed that back
into the game loop.
Or we could also
then in addition to,
we could push that to BigQuery
and persistent for soon
in future analysis.
TINO TERESHKO: Totally.
And thinking back to my
days as a data scientist
in ads, which is its
own kind of game,
I used to work in building
recommendation engines for ads.
What practically happens
for user data scientists,
which would be the type
of user, oftentimes,
who is sitting in front
of the BigQuery interface.
And you're doing
ad hoc querying,
you're testing
hypotheses very quickly.
And as you find
things that work,
you practically push
them up the stack.
You go and talk to
the engineers who
write data field code, once
you find that right combination
of levers that
need to be pulled,
and you start implementing
the things that came out
of your ad hoc
querying in Dataflow,
or if you're not
on Dataflow, you're
going from whatever it is
your ad hoc solution is
to wherever it is that
your life code is running.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I was actually just
thinking, so say I
am a game developer, or some
sort of application developer
with a lot of
interface interaction
and a lot of data
coming through.
And I want to implement
this strategy.
Should I start by working
on say, the Pub/Sub end?
Should I start by just
implementing BigQuery
and [INAUDIBLE] data into that?
How much of this should I try
and take it in one big go?
What's the easiest step?
Should I go BigQuery, then
maybe add Dataflow down the line
and then Pub/Sub down the line?
Or should I start with Pub/Sub?
What's my entry point here?
I'm sure you all
have different--
ERIC ANDERSON: We'll give you
three different entry points.
I would say for
a game developer,
it really does very much depends
on where your data is today.
If you're like
minigame developers,
using App Engine
for a front end,
you have a fantastic option
which is just cloud logging.
You can import or export,
rather, all of your logs
directly from App Engine
into Big Query or Pub/Sub.
And so I would
say there-- again,
depending on how you're
writing your logs--
you should start with BigQuery.
Because when you don't
know exactly what you're
trying to implement,
you should start
with the add hoc solution.
Look at all your logs,
see what you can find out.
when you export
for all logs, you
have an ability to
analyze it very quickly.
But because the schema
are not applied,
because you're not
enriching the data,
you're not necessarily getting
the best out of the data
or your workflow is
not necessarily great.
It's a bit of a pain.
And so if you get
to a place, as I'm
sure you will,
where you are seeing
some return on that work,
where you're starting
to get some insights about
what the users are doing,
the swords are good,
pickaxes are not so good.
That's where you need to
go to the Cloud Console
and say, hey, now let's try
this Dataflow and Pub/Sub thing.
So you can start publishing
your logs to Pub/Sub, and then
from there, bringing
up Dataflow job
to analyze then transform,
then apply the schema
and go to BigQuery.
I think your third
step might be OK
now that you've sort of taken
stuff that you've been dumping
to logs and put it
through this pipeline,
you've gotten comfortable,
instead of writing to logs
and then sort of recovering that
data from Google Cloud Logging,
you may just publish
directly to Pub/Sub.
That's a possibility.
I think a very
exciting entry point
for some of the game
developers, and maybe
for website and services
developers-- actually really,
anybody who uses who
uses Google Analytics,
there's another direct
entry point with BigQuery.
Is that right, Tino?
I was talking about the
export, that there's
a one flavor where you
get all of your data
already parsed and
nicely packaged.
How does that work?
TINO TERESHKO: Yes,
there's a Google Analytics
Premium is enterprise level
offering of Google Analytics.
And it comes with
daily BigQuery experts.
MARK MANDEL: It
was pretty sweet.
I used it for the last
Android app we developed,
where we instrumented the
app to report all the events.
It wasn't a game.
It was an app for booking rooms.
But it was pretty sweet to just
have all that data in BigQuery
curry immediately without
any intermediate steps.
TINO TERESHKO: I think a
lot of the gaming companies
that we see start--
BigQuery's so easy to use
and so easy to get started with.
We even have public
data sets in BigQuery
that you don't even need to
know SQL to start using them.
We pre-built dashboards for
our customers to look at.
It's so easy to get
started with BigQuery,
and it helps you understand
the shape of your data very,
very quickly, in a
very ad hoc fashion.
The folks generally
try BigQuery first,
and then as their
pipelines mature,
as they want to
go more real time,
as they want to enrich the data
or create that feedback loop,
they start implementing
inevitably Dataflow and Pub/Sub
into that equation as well.
That's my take.
ERIC ANDERSON:
And I think what's
interesting about
what we've said so far
about how you set up these
pipelines initially and grow
them is there's
no throwaway code,
there is no decision that says,
oh, this is how you prototype.
And then once you rescale, you
have to throw that all away.
And then you do
it this other way,
which is much more complicated
and has fewer features,
but it can handle
the scale you need.
The way you set p your pipeline
for scale or for prototype
is the same, and in both cases,
it's fairly straightforward.
Going back to what Kir said
about starting out with
logs in BigQuery or
a Pub/Sub pipeline.
In either case, Dataflow
logic can be re-used.
So you can write a batch job
on a BigQuery log export,
and then once you pipe
that in through Pub/Sub,
you can apply that same
logic, the same code,
to the streaming pipeline.
Also, Dataflow comes with
a local running solution.
So if you want to mess on
your laptop from a Pub/Sub
or from BigQuery, that same
experience works there locally,
and then you just push it to
the cloud for the scale runs.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So unfortunately, this
is a great conversation,
but we are running out of
time just a little bit.
I will go through each of you.
If there's anything
we haven't covered,
and I'm sure there's a lot, but
you want to highlight or plug,
please feel free
to do so and then
I we're going to have to
wrap up, unfortunately.
Going by order of appearance,
Kir, did you want to go first?
KIR TITIEVSKY: No, I
don't want this to end.
Too much fun.
No, but I'll say this.
I think this notion that
there is a service that
allows you to connect
things in the cloud
and it will work like
logging system where you just
dump messages into
it, and they can
be recovered at any point
anywhere in the world,
is a pretty amazing
prospect for me.
And just in general, the
Pub/Sub paradigm in itself
is pretty cool once you start
getting into the distributed
computing side of computing,
which is everything today.
And in Cloud Pub/Sub,
that's just kind
of delivered to you on a silver
platter, it just kind of works.
So I would encourage
game developers
and really, anybody who is
interested in collecting data
from their mobile
apps or website
apps to think about
how all the data
from the different endpoints
and the different services
comes together.
It's not just plain
networking anymore.
You've got to have
something a little fancier.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And Eric?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure,
thanks for having me.
I'm very excited to see what
these game developers do.
When you have time to devote to
actually developing your game
and getting insights
from your data
and not standing up
distributed analytical pipeline
systems and
babysitting clusters,
I think awesome things happen.
So thanks for having us,
and I'm excited to see
what people build.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And finally, Tino?
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah,
thanks for having me, guys.
I will add that if folks want
to find out more about what's
possible, I would encourage
you to look at a YouTube
video of the Google
Cloud Platform
next, which is a conference
that we had in March.
On of our awesome
customers, Kabam Games,
they make marble games and
"Fast and the Furious" games,
they spent about 25
minutes discussing
how they're using BigQuery
and all the other services
that we have and it's a really,
really interesting use case.
They discover how folks make
in-game purchase decisions.
What about where the
most fraud comes from?
Or if they introduce bosses
that are overpowering,
how do they discover that?
How do I understand
when there are
imperfections in their games?
And potentially, what's
even more interesting
is that Kabam Games
launches a lot of titles.
And they're not sure
when some of these titles
can be small or very successful.
And BigQuery,
Dataflow, and Pub/Sub
allows them to not
think about scale.
They built the same
way for one customer
as they do for 10
million customers.
That's a great luxury
for a game developer.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so much
to the three of you
for taking the time to
share that very interesting
conversation with us.
ERIC ANDERSON: Thank you, Mark.
Thank you, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Bye guys.
ERIC ANDERSON: Cheers.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
TINO TERESHKO: Cheers.
Have a good one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
again to Kir, Eric, and Tino
for such an interesting
conversation.
I learned a lot about it, and
I hope that you got excited
about the whole idea of putting
those three different products
together to basically
understand better
what your application
and people are
doing with their applications.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, I
really actually liked it.
I learned a lot,
particularly about Dataflow.
I hadn't really
thought about what
was possible in terms of the
transformation aspect of it.
I found that
particularly interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I'm very excited.
Let's see if some
of our listeners
have some similar story
of how they're using,
and maybe you can
send us a little bit
about how you're doing it, or
your questions and comments
about it.
We're looking forward
to that, as always.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And why don't we
go with the question
of the week?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this is, I think,
an interesting one,
especially based on what
we're talking about today.
Looking at BigQuery, and
it may be it's something
that you want to play with.
But you don't have maybe a
big data set of your own.
Maybe you're like, I don't
have just terabytes of data
lying around, it's not
something I generally do.
So are there data
sets available to me
that I can just get
in and play with,
and see the power of
BigQuery and see whether it's
a really good fit for me?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And the answer,
obviously, is yes.
I've been using these for demos
because it is pretty cool.
You can basically just go
there and start running queries
on huge data sets.
And we have a link on the
show notes to that data set.
It's somewhere like
Cloud.Google.com
/BigQuery/PublicData.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty close.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Something like that.
And you will see that
we have a bunch of them.
There's like USA names.
So you can see all the different
names and from the births
that are occurred
in the United States
since 1879, which has
been quite a while.
So you can do
analysis like, what
was the most common name
during a year or in the '90s
or whatever?
You can totally do that,
and it's very easy.
There's also some
others that are actually
surprisingly interesting.
Like, we have all the comments,
all the stories and comments
from "Hacker News" from 2006.
So you can do a lot of really
cool analysis based on that.
I know that the demo
from "Next" used
these data sets to create things
like what primary language
people cursed most
and things like that.
Like there was "Hacker News."
I don't know if GitHub is here.
MARK MANDEL: There was some
data there from GitHub,
I definitely saw that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So anyway, there's a bunch
of different data sets,
and you can definitely
check them out.
The good thing is
that you're going
to be able to click there
and then go directly
to the BigQuery
console where you
can start running your queries.
MARK MANDEL: And you can
do up to, what is it,
a terabyte of
processing for free?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I think it's either
a terabyte or five terabytes.
I don't remember right now,
but it's a lot of data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
you can totally do that.
So it gives you a good chance
to really play with it,
get your feet wet, and
maybe probably find
some interesting things
happening in some big data
sets.
I'm seeing there's a data
set here for "Dota 2."
I'm kind of curious to
see what's in there.
Well, excellent, Francesc.
Thank you very much for
joining me yet again this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
I guess since it's Episode 30
and we have been on for quite a
while, should we--
MARK MANDEL: Remind
people where they
can get in contact with us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly what
I was trying to say, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I know.
You've been bicycling
for a long time, it's OK.
I understand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we have a webpage.
MARK MANDEL: GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And not only that,
but Cloud.Google.com/Podcast
now.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [INAUDIBLE].
We are on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: At /r/GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Google+.
MARK MANDEL: At +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I think that's it.
MARK MANDEL: On Slack,
there is #Podcast.
And also they can contact us
by email, hello@GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, looking forward to all
of your messages regarding
these episodes and others,
and talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]